Tony a fisherman has been living in a
house by the lake since he was young
over the years the lake is becoming more
popular and one day a large Hotel gets
built the hotel obscures all the
sunlight and the guests leave their
trash on the beach to Tony these are
negative externalities although the good
smell of the freshly roasted coffee from
the coffee shop that opened right next
to the hotel is a positive externality
things start getting complicated when a
paper Factory begins polluting the river
that flows down the mountain into the
lake where Tony and the other fishermen
earn a living can you think of the
effects the factory may have on the
community you may pause the video and
share your thoughts before we continue
foreign
the Paper Factory is using clean water
from the mountain river through the
production process the water gets dirty
and afterwards the polluted water is put
back into the river this water then
kills a lot of fish Downstream a cost to
society that no one covers Tony and the
fishermen start to fear for their
existence and then things get worse
the paper mill which doesn't Factor the
cost of dead fish into their cost of
production is therefore charging too
little when selling the paper as a
consequence the paper is so cheap that
the coffee shop starts using disposable
cups where they were using porcelain
before this again leads to more
production of paper more polluted water
more fish dying and more trash on the
beach Tony is getting anxious
foreign
to change the situation the farmers
decide to Stage public protests until
the local government announces a new law
the factory is now forced to fully
internalize the costs of their Waste
Management through the installation of
filters soon after the water is clean
again and Tony and the other fishermen
can go back to selling the same amount
of fish they used to and since the price
of paper goes up to cover the cost of
the filtration system the coffee shop
began serving drinks in real cups again
we can illustrate what is happening on a
supply and demand chart with price and
quantity demanded for the paper in an
unregulated Market the factory supplies
its products based on so-called private
costs such as construction salaries and
the raw materials demand meets Supply
accordingly if the Paper Factory would
have added the cost of the damages that
it causes to society the supply curve
would have shifted to the left leading
to an equilibrium reflecting the true
costs including the social costs now the
price of paper is higher and the
quantity of paper demanded is lower
pollution and other negative
externalities are especially prevalent
where people lack the same moral values
and where things tend to be free of
charge such as the case with water or
air
fishing at high seas is such a case
since no one can fully control the
oceans and the high sea doesn't really
belong to anyone everyone takes as much
as they can a phenomenon called The
Tragedy of the commons
to combat negative externalities and
avoid such a tragedy we can do four
things create public awareness assign
property rights appropriately Force the
internalization of negative
externalities or turn to regulation and
fines
[Music]
let's summarize externalities are
consequences of an activity experienced
by a third party negative externalities
that are not internalized distort supply
and demand at the expense of third
parties to avoid Market Distortion and a
tragedy of the commons we can combat
negative externalities ready to help us
think how to do that in order to curb
CO2 emissions
[Music]
people that drive cars that run on
petrol cause emissions including CO2
which is responsible for air pollution
and climate change in order to reduce
emissions some governments give their
citizens a financial incentive if they
buy an electric car imagine you are the
minister of Transportation in your
country could you think of another way
to increase the number of electric cars
on the streets by applying the concept
of externalities please write down your
ideas in the comments below
foreign
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com